hello grammarians today we're going to
talk about subject verb agreement and
what this is
is the idea that you want your subject
and your verb to get along in a sentence
what
agreement is in grammar is the art of
making sure that sentence parts connect
with one another in the right way
it's making sure you know that a
square peg
goes in a square hole
right not a square peg in round hole
square peg in a triangular hole you want
to make sure that
the way you make
the way you render your subject
fits with the way you've rendered your
verb so what do i mean by that so let's
let's take the sentence
the dog barks
so we have this subject the dog and it
is singular
there's one of it and the way this verb
is the word is conjugated the way this
verb is conjugated the way we've
assembled or figured out how the verb is
going to be is also a singular
conjugation
so we say the dog barks and not
the dog
bark
right this is not
standard american english like this this
doesn't this does not this is the plural
form
you can say the dogs bark right because
there's more than one dog here and this
is their this is the verb this is the
plural form i know it's kind of strange
that the third person singular form
of a verb
ends in s like if english made sense
like okay if i if i ran the zoo right
like i would want it to work like this
the dog's barks right because there's an
s there's multiple unfortunately for
many weird reasons and the history of
english it doesn't it didn't work out
that way a third person singular verb
usually ends in an s
right so
i talk
that's first person third person is she
talks
we eat
that's
plural first person
they
eat see no s it's only this weird
third person singular here that's got
that s
on the end so if you're trying to if
you're trying to figure out how to make
something agree if you're unsure as
you're writing so if you're looking at a
sentence like the dog's
bark and you can't figure out if it's
supposed to be the dog's bark or the dog
barks or the dog's barks
ask yourself first
what is the subject of the sentence so
first find the subject and then
ask yourself
is it singular or plural is it s or p is
it salt or is it pepper and then if you
can remember that
then just remember
that singular s
usually results in another s so if it's
the dog
and that's singular then you're going to
want to put that s
over here so if the subject isn't a noun
but a pronoun same question is it
singular or plural
i is singular there's only one me we is
plural there's many of us and if it's
singular third person so like she he
it
uh end it in an s another thing to
remember uh is that most what we call
indefinite pronouns
are third person singular so if you
wanted to ask whether or not anyone
knows the way to san jose as a question
but you're not sure uh whether or not it
would be does anyone know the way to san
jose or do anyone know the way to san
jose well the word anyone
is third person singular and although do
is an irregular verb we still kind of
hold to the idea that a third person
singular verb ends in an s so it's a z
sound
written as an s
so we would say does
so does anyone know as opposed to you
know if it were in the plural
do we
know
right so does the singular do is plural
and that's kind of the basic idea of
subject verb agreement is you want to
make sure
that the number
of things in your subject matches up
with the number in your predicate so as
the subject singular or plural if it's
third person singular the verb probably
ends in an s even though
the third person singular
noun or pronoun does not you can learn
anything
dave it out